j'en ai une sur les blagues aussi que la
base il m'a dit je suis en fin de
semaine sur les baguettes à un bec qui
rencontre son pote et son pote mini
sahara il fait bien là il fait alors
qu'est ce tu fais bam fille fille
figure toi que j'ai il se trouvait du du
boulot il fait c'est hyper bien et bien
tu fais quoi
ben je bosse eu un affront français tu
télécom différemment il es tu fais quoi
il dit rien répond au téléphone il a
quand même
il s'est dit vraiment a eu du pot et dit
tu fais quoi bamba bacon gros c'est le
tube et c'est moi qui ai fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
du beau monde au mondial juste valeur et
patrick bosso à côté de moi alors ces
deux sur le port de marseille devant
deux comme ça de poissons tutelle papote
elle rigole tout les deux il ya un vide
v tu sais quoi et beh je marie ma fille
alors le très ludique aux non pas celle
là battez pas géométriques absurde sur
marseille mazicou absurde sur marseille
c'est maigre haendel bach comme serena
le bar est là il voit le patron derrière
le comptoir en train de suer les verts
comme ça et puis au dessus du patro il
ya une poisson empaillés mais énorme un
gros poisson comme ça le mec il regarde
le patron il regarde le poisson énorme à
mme paillé au dessus y aura le patron et
lui fera les chemins il dit qui c'est le
moteur qui a pêché ça s'éteint à paris
match
on dit aux reporters spéciale du faut
absolument qu'on fasse un un papier sur
sa patte à sur sa patte en mai écoute tu
te démerdes moi je veux un reportage sur
sa patte à el mex conseil et il ya un
mec un vieux mec avion au mexique 1-1
connu zapata de son vivant alors il va
prendre l'avion il arriva au mexique un
petit point dont il monte il monte dans
dans une petite chiara c'est rien c'est
qu'une montagne espagnole est là au pied
d'un pommier voit les mexicains excusez
moi de vous déranger paraît que vous
connaissiez zapata mois sa patte à
djabou racontèrent c'était en 1896 yassa
patat qui est leur maman moi je suis en
train de créer deux des fleurs pour ma
femme sapata
ces droits-là lille parce que j'admirais
c'est top
il me dit avec son fusil il me dit tout
à des amis enlève ton pantalon mais s'il
n'y a pas de ton pantalon je t'éclate
j'enlève mon pantalon tout ce cas
mais ne vous va pas nous les matches
j'ai mangé dans ces moments là il ya une
rayon de soleil qui fait peur aux shebab
les schémas le secam sapata il tombe par
terre je pense jacques faucher dès
maintenant tout est en même temps pas de
talent mais tais toi même ils avaient
tous fait pareil que kaka tout le monde
ça va ça je connais on a mangé ensemble
lipper
28 alors si de ces deux ouvriers y
travaillent pour une maison
et puis il fonde entretien d'une fosse
septique
mais là encore plein alors les deux sens
une manip et puis tombe dedans ils ont
ils ont de la sueur jusqu'à la lèvre
inférieure du qatar de la merde jusqu'à
la mer intérieure et l'autre dit [ __ ]
tu choisis joseba pour moi mourir
apatride y est à savoir n'arrive encore
bas j'ai envie de la chine
[Rires]
vite
[Applaudissements]